do you guys know what the real problem
with the last Jedi is you know what man
I actually really liked the last Jedi I
am so sick of talking about the last
Jedi oh [ __ ] guys a new Star Wars
trailer just dropped either reject
nation I'm Greg Alba and I'm John
Humphrey
I'm Andrew Gordon follow and ruin the
movie source channel thanks for being
here my dude yes do some work in a
little bit so we got to get out of here
really fast before we hop into this
trailer
thank you guys who are following us in
the Stardust app we're trying to get to
10 K followers as soon as possible we
post daily over there over there we do
thirty second reaction reviews for any
film TV show and or trailer some of them
are micro sketches you can post reviews
reactions yourselves on there as well so
do it today let's get into this
hmm [ __ ] yeah okay we passed on all we
know the thousand generations living you
know but this is your fight nipple
chills already
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
yeah
[Music]
do
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow
[Laughter]
wait a minute now
right is the sky I thought the sky
Walker thing was ending okay whoo maybe
they realized that fans did that was a
very unexpected title we didn't mean
that our period the Rises Scott Walker
than to go wait a minute for the rise of
Skywalker what is that oh dude that was
how is uh that's a very striking
trailers for sure it looks bad it looks
like we're getting a lot of Jedi action
in there too yeah at that opening
sequence you know I love the tension in
the mood there and you know like this is
a cool action shot of her doing the head
hold flip was that kylo attacking her in
that moment kind of look like it I feel
like there's always some of the gloves
yeah I guess yeah it was posed what are
we doing let's watch it again it's
really what do we do
lower it so we can talk over it all
right yeah this this kind of reminds me
of a Kill Bill this is taking its time
like all the image is very steady very
fluid hmm I love the camerawork in this
trailer - honestly the teaser face no
past on all we know
these are lines recorded for the movie
right and generations generations so
she's unified so it's like it's all the
Jedi her within her maybe she's just
carrying on the Skywalker mantle or
something maybe she's to see if this guy
Walker after all yeah
Star Wars the course corrections I love
it yeah and she's like full-on warrior
in this one certainly is such a great
shot yeah inner Sarah Connor and Ellen
Ripley on well I like how the music
isn't completely dark like it kind of
has that romantic this sequence looks
freakin bad with the red Harry is fixing
his helmet there's Paris to prevent
that's cool I just fly in the Millennium
Falcon love with you yeah good old times
whoa just a good pilot man you see c-3po
there
that's a tall that's a great shot that
is a pretty shot I knew the new Trinity
con no one's ever really gone who is
having their the rise of Palpatine
what's your guys's guess to that
Palpatine's grandson its Luke again I
really did love that trailer I love that
you do see c-3po there I'm just making
another cameo or it's gonna be an actual
character and I seem like that shot with
Lando steering the Millennium Falcon in
the back right there it looks like his
outfit is with Donald Glover war and
soul oh yeah a little bit Oh Andrew but
where your thoughts my friend the trail
was really cool as the nice tease I
think you know ray definitely looks like
warrior in this one for sure she's got
really over him at that Jedi skills that
first shot was incredible but like to me
I know I kind of mentioned this but I
loved the camera work in this just how
like a lot of the POV shots and just how
the cameras working with a lot of the
space sales like shots I just thought
that was really interesting and I don't
know maybe I'm wrong but I didn't feel
like it was this does feel like a JJ
Abrams feel like it's got that touch to
it a little bit it does have that JJ
Abrams right where's the flare shot I
mean honestly this is kind of my
favorite part of the role out for movies
like this is the teaser phase I really
like the approach to this because it
come compared to some of the previous
ones you know I feel like this is very
simple in a way it's just a few shots I
like the fact that it's a lot of just
desolate landscapes and not too much in
the way of Oh crazy creatures in world
right it's kind of contained so it's
getting me wondering but I also really
just like the mood and the tone that
they went for I'm curious about that
scene where she's facing off with the
ship the ship yeah just because I'm like
is this going to serve like a true
purpose or is this just gonna be like a
cool moment of some kind of me dad if it
was the opening I remember a rogue one
there was that shop where she Felicity
was a little there's gonna be it's a TIE
fighter that's something that was not
that's gonna I feel like this is
definitely the scene in the movie that
seemed weird and of course the Sopron of
course the Carrie Fisher moment I mean
it looks so it's like you have to
digital her and obviously look I mean
they said something like they were
taking some scenes that were already
shot and putting it in here or I've
heard multiple angles from it that
sometimes we're gonna take some deleted
moments from like last Jedi or did the
sequences of rorish
or this movie it didn't look like I'm
gonna be distracted or finding it weird
I feel like they're gonna do their
absolute best to pay proper respects in
that moment yeah it looks like she'll
have a presence but maybe not be like
you know oh we proceed you may kinda
like in rogue one the end when we see
the CGI I love that shot to where kylo
is just in battle you got that waver it
looks like a non you know usually when I
hear the think of Star Wars and the
fights it's like you know a lot of laser
guns and the ship battles and you get
some mad with a PO just doing whatever
that ship is that was a tracking shot it
doesn't you know cut it all there that's
he's like just looks like we got some
great action sequences now I agreed but
my main question for this trailer where
the poor's where the port where
merchandise yeah we did see the new
droid yeah do Ronnie James Dio I and
also with Mark Hamill's lines there it
feels like if it's appropriate to have
his even though what happened with him
having his lines there and saying the
rise of the Skywalker it does seem likes
in some way she's carrying on the
philosophical legacy and that the
Skywalker's hell because I don't know
I'd feel if they said like no she's
actually really a Skywalker you know but
they're cloning the rise of the
Skywalker so that's where I'm a little
bit that that's definitely a title to
hear it and I then am like I gotta go
find out what they mean by that and I
think this way people say why yeah yeah
wonder how long they've known this is
gonna be the title I gotta say that that
last shot of the Death Star cracked up
and stuff like that that really got me
that looked like something out of a
sci-fi sure I so remind me a little
before so awakens when we saw that ship
on jakku that was like at the end of
from the battle right alright guys well
what did you think of this trailer any
predictions why do you think it's called
rise of the skywalker oh boy you know
what we should do if we wrap this video
up i would like to give a page from the
day shadow to a handsome man named
kay Linden McHale has just turned 40
today it's his actual birthday
I think it's 40 I would say a 40 year
old virgin choke but if you've seen this
guy you know he is using his lightsaber
left and right if you know what I mean
well the horse is with him oh yeah I
mean he's not forcing himself it's all
yeah yeah it's all consensual sent to
duels may the consent be with you yes
and also with you but only if you want
it
happy birthday McHale we're having a
good time on your trip you guys can
subscribe at the reject nation click
that notification bell and follow Andrea
on the movie source channel and please
don't forget to download and follow us
in the Stardust app do it today